>> Okay, well, there's been a lot of discussion
here about the Middle
East.
I was on the panel on the balance of power
in the Middle East yesterday
because one of the world's most retractible
problems is the conflict
between Israelis and Palestinians that's went
on for such a long time.
So there is a lot of discussion here about
what to do about that
because the Palestinian Prime Minister, Mr.
Fayyad, the Prime Minister
of Jordan, the King of Jordan is coming here.
And we are really looking in the coming year
for some new impetus
behind the Middle East peace process.
President Obama really put some effort behind
that in 2009, it hasn't
borne a lot of fruit yet.
So we really need an incoming British government,
whoever wins the
general election in a few months time, also
needs to put some new
momentum behind that process.
Not so much there are new ideas here; there
aren't really any new ideas
in Middle East peace matters.
It's how to get agreement on Israelis and
Palestinians discussing
things properly together again.